thanks for joining us at 11 o'clock I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis motor
vehicle thefts up almost 50 percent
higher than this time last year that
according to the latest numbers from
Metro Police it is a disturbing Trend
but officers say crooks are targeting
some specific car models Brian will
joining us now live with our top story
to tell us which cars are most at risk
and what you can do to keep safe
if you drive a Hyundai or a Kia built
between 2010 and 2021 you could be the
most at risk it's all thanks to a
disturbing trend on social media that
Metro Police say is thieves showing
people how easy it is to start some of
these vehicles
it's been worse worse yeah and they
can't figure out who it is they just
steal your car and it's gone basically I
just think it's bad you know it's like
why would you steal a car that's the
question many residents are asking after
an alarming number of car thefts so far
this year it's our law enforcement
partners are out there dealing with
violent crime and something as as little
as a car theft to to them there's just
not enough time to get to it and you
have a community that is continuously
growing as well a recent Tick-Tock
challenge is contributing to the problem
showing users how to compromise
ignitions on certain Hyundai and Kia
models but there are steps you can take
to protect your ride including some new
technology find the dash cams that are
capable with GPS that you can set that
up and mount it to your windshield or to
your dash devices like that can even
kill your car's ignition so thieves
won't be going anywhere with your
vehicle
making sure that you make it as hard as
possible to be to not be a victim and I
think that's the actually the the key
but if the worst does happen be prepared
if all your paperwork for your license
plate in your vehicle is in your vehicle
then it's going to be a bad day right so
at least have a picture of what your
vehicle looks like the VIN number and
all that information handy and store it
somewhere inside your house so if
something like that occurs you can
properly notify law enforcement
of course there are some basic things
you can do to protect yourself like lock
your vehicle anytime you leave it and
park in a well-lit area another tip is
look for security cameras as they can
help deter some crimes but also if your
car is stolen then they can help locate
it live near the strip Brian will eight
news now